a suspected peeping Tom and wanting
murder suspect is shot and killed by
police after a high-speed chase through
Rhode Island ends in a crash and
shootout
on May 23rd police were called to a
Johnston Rhode Island neighborhood about
15 minutes outside of capital city
Providence Thomas May reported his
neighbor 52-year-old James Harrison was
peeping through his 15-year-old
daughter's window even using a ladder to
see inside at the time May asked to file
a trespass order against Harrison but
when officers couldn't find him they
left the next day Harrison allegedly
shot and killed his mother Janet
Harrison and Thomas May May's 15 year
old daughter was also shot and injured
kill three people
420 us
d
[Music]
and
on May 24th officers returned to
Harrison's home to file the trespass
order just in time to see him drive off
officials say he made a gesture showing
he was armed
the Northland
Riverbend
at the original scene First Responders
found the 15 year old girl lying on the
ground struggling after she'd been shot
her father was found inside the garage
Dead with a gunshot wound to the Head
officials say Harrison also shot his
mother in the head she was found inside
his home body camera video from Cranston
Police Officer shows officials catch up
with Harrison in a cemetery
no
66 they only enter squat
s locations
Cemetery
is coming out with me
67 you take it off
down Cranston Street
after that body camera video from more
than a dozen officers shows a Chase
throughout the area
get the exit locked
up
56 locations
for the cemetery
is coming along with me
60 seconds later
on Cranston Street eastbound
he's on Cranston Street
approach to the fire station
fire Avenue
head on with multiple vehicles
Washington uh pleasure here
we're still going to play again I'm not
sure I would have him
went through Outland Avenue
Riverbend limited he's head on
66 Providence NC police let him know
in this city
we're trying to Ram this car
17.
negative
hate him
up
10.50
we're going
to happen where you probably are good
prior to a cruiser all right we're gonna
be going north on Plainfield
scratch that oh
westbound Plainfield
Pikeville
so it's all about playing field
Southbound
whatever
I almost just hit two pedestrians
all right
let me
location
the high-speed chase lasts for several
minutes ending only when Harrison
crashes body camera video shows multiple
officers Rush from their vehicles toward
Harrison
kill yourself
hey back up back up back up back up
kill the siren
is moving around
[Music]
thank you
hands up hands up video then shows
officers approach Harrison and his
vehicle when he allegedly points his
handgun at police they open fire
come outside
[Music]
body camera video shows the same moments
from multiple different angles
what's this
[Music]
oh my God
who's better Michael
hey bro
[Applause]
[Music]
after the shooting First Responders
rushed toward Harrison and put him in
handcuffs
officers from both Cranston and
Providence opened fire Harrison was shot
and died as a result of his injuries the
shooting is now under investigation by
the Rhode Island attorney general's
office reporting for a long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie